zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live zweiter versuch heute den
ersten versuch mussten wir abbrechen
wegen tonproblemen jetzt läuft aber das
heißt wir können anfangen und über ein
thema reden dass gerade doch heiß
diskutiert wird denn die pandemie die
trifft uns zwar alle gleich heißt es
immer ist aber wenn man auf die fakten
guckt überhaupt nicht so wenn man sich
anschaut wo die korona infektionszahlen
besonders hoch sind dann fällt auf dass
das besonders da der fall ist wo viele
menschen auf engem raum leben da gibt es
mehr wird infektionen
das liegt teilweise daran dass es
menschen sind die mit niedrigem
einkommen dort leben weil natürlich nach
großer wohnraum kostet mehr geld kleiner
wohnraum kostet weniger geld aber auch
der anteil von menschen mit
migrationsgeschichte ist in diesen
bezirken häufig höher
deswegen wolle man heute diskutieren
welchen einfluss haben so faktoren wie
einkommen bildung job wohnsituation aber
auch soziokultureller background auf die
infektionszahlen und was macht die
politik um in diesen gebieten das ganze
in den griff zu kriegen hat sie genug
getan oder ist da noch luft nach oben
das ganze diskutieren wir heute mit
bettina dickes von der cdu landrätin im
kreis im kreis bad kreuznach wo es
mehrere corona ausbrüche gab unter
anderem in deutsch russischen gemeinden
mit muss adedy leiter des
gesundheitszentrums für migrantinnen und
migranten in köln das ist eine
einrichtung des paritätischen
wohlfahrtsverbandes auch einmalig in
deutschland und bei mir im studio ich
freue mich sehr in dieser armani
künstlerin menschenrechtsaktivistin und
eine starke stimme für die belange von
minderheiten in deutschland und weltweit
ich freue mich dass sie alle hier bei
mir und natürlich mit euch fragen und
kommentare wie immer in die dafür
vorgesehenen kommentarspalten per e mail
an zdf heute - live at zdf.de und weil
das ein thema ist wo ich weiß das ist
dazu kommen kann
alles was rassistisch diskriminierend
beleidigend et cetera et cetera ist
werden wir so schnell wie möglich aus
den kommentaren entfernen und die
nutzerinnen und nutzer so schnell wie
möglich blocken deswegen lass es einfach
denn dann haben wir weniger arbeit und
eine bessere diskussion
ich fange mal diskussion an mit einem
zitat von gesundheitsminister jetzt
sparen anlässlich des im griff ist hat
er in einem zeitungsinterview gesagt
es ist so ich habe gesagt es gibt
bestimmte gruppen das kennen wir auch
von anderen impfungen wo wir starke
werben müssen für eine impfung das gilt
eben vor allem auch bei bestimmten
kulturellen hintergründen wenn in dem
heimatland oder dem land wo die familie
herkommt impfen nicht so populär ist
dann ist es auch manchmal hier so und
das versuchen wir eben zu adressieren
durch information pro armani wenn sie
das hören würden sie den
gesundheitsminister da recht geben oder
widersprechen
ich glaube ich finde mangels eines
besseren borders ist ein bisschen so die
reling muster stattfindet also nicht
entgleisen sondern so ablenken von der
situation weil einfach ist unsere vision
morgen grünen ja also ist es sicherlich
also die das problem ist einfach ist
trifft sozial schwacher menschen und
ärmere menschen völlig egal ob mit oder
ohne hintergrund mit oder ohne
migrationshintergrund also es ist
einfach ganz klar dass sie bei einer
krise da übrigens auch egal welche krise
wenn ein land in eine krise geht dann
sind probleme die es vorher schon gab
werden natürlich viel viel deutlicher
treten die zutage man sieht plötzlich wo
gibt es probleme in deutschland zum
beispiel ist auch eine fehlende
digitalisierung der schulen gewesen ich
persönlich weiß das weil wir viele viele
schüler und abiturienten wirklich so
hilfe in dieser höhe würde sich dann
immer so ich denke ich weiß auch gerade
nicht was ich tun konnte
genau die haben tatsächlich so was
geschrieben wie wir machen aber ich habe
zum beispiel ein laptop der halb kaputt
ist der nicht mehr mit vier geschwistern
teilen muss viele alleinerziehende
mutter die mich angeschrieben haben und
tatsächlich auch einfach sehr sehr viele
menschen ohne migrationshintergrund also
ich fand es einfach schade
daneben auch im wahlkampf ich hab' ich
bin keine politikerin ich habe kein
wahlkampf ich hab mich mal irgendein
buch was ich dazu verkaufen möchte oder
so sondern dann ist eine herkunft
debatte daraus zu machen ganz klar in
deutschland gibt es armut und das sind
leider oft sogar die menschen die die
werden immer so dargestellt als sozial
schwach es sind aber oft menschen die
gerade das soziale leben auch am laufen
halten das land also die pflegeberufe
die leute die am fließband stehen die
leute die die busse fahren die leute und
die haben oft einfach nicht die mittel
die sind nicht so privilegiert um sich
entsprechend zu schützen also zum
beispiel die sitzen nicht immer
acht zimmer altbauwohnung beim home
office mit einem cappuccino sondern die
sind vielleicht zu fünft oder zu dritt
oder so in einer einzimmerwohnung da
kommt dann wieder dazu gesamt dass man
muss das im gesamtgesellschaftlichen
kontext sehen das ist tatsächlich ein
sozio ökonomisches problem ist auch ich
zum beispiel bin in einer privilegierten
situation ich kann mir auch dann leisten
zu sagen jetzt arbeite ich von zu hause
oder ich gehe da und da nicht hin oder
ich sage das sind das ab und ist will
nun aber schnitt nicht und in
deutschland ist dass ich glaube da ist
sich inzwischen fast ganz deutschland
einig so werden die interessen der der
industrie gerade sehr gewagt so will
schatten nicht dauern die leute sind am
am fließband und so weiter da müssen die
arbeiten aber leute dürfen nachts nicht
spazieren gehen aber sollen dann
irgendwie am fließband trotzdem stehen
und müssen dann noch mit den
öffentlichen mitteln dahin fahren also
ein grundproblem ist es gibt armut in
deutschland mit und ohne
migrationshintergrund und die ist nicht
wenig die frankfurter rundschau sind
schönen artikel geschrieben
16 prozent in deutschland sind an der
armutsgrenze
und ja da gibt es auch leute mit
migrationsgeschichte ohne ende frauen
ohne ende allein erziehende mütter und
diese probleme sobald eine krise ist es
könnte auch eine völlig andere krise
sein zeigt sich dass eben und daraus
dann mitten im wahlkampf so eine
spezifische herkunfts debatte zu machen
und dann sozusagen aber das ist ein
kulturelles problem und so halte ich für
sehr populistisch dann auch und muss man
einfach klar sagen sollte das nicht
gerecht weil du musst auch selber dann
über dich selbst nicht eingestehen ja
ich bin in der privilegierten position
ich weiß gar nicht wie sich jemand der
einem randgebiet wohnt der tenor ihren
armut oft in deutschland wie ignorieren
das weil die geografisch weiter weg sind
oder weil es uns hier egal entsperrten
wir auch wo ja ja und oft im
randbezirken oder eben in
virtualisierten gruppen und so und das
hat ist keine migrationsdebatte für mich
dass es eine armutsdebatte und leute aus
finanziell schwächeren situationen mit
berufen die trotzdem für dieses land
sehr wichtig sind und da muss man mal
gucken möchte ja muss er dazu die arbeit
in köln eben auch tatsächlich in einem
gebiet wo viele menschen leben für
den paritätischen wohlfahrtsverband in
diesem gesundheitszentrum wien nehmen
sieht diese problematik war also würden
sie jetzt ehefrau armani recht geben
oder herrn sparen ist das eine armut
oder eine herkunft debatte da geb ich
frau armani rechte und das kann ich hier
gar nicht so sehen wie herr spahn
ich bin ein sehr wichtiger aspekt das
ist die information und die aufklärung
weil sich schutzmaßnahmen und um die
erkrankung leider geht die politik davon
aus dass die bevölkerung mit
migrationshintergrund sich über die
printmedien sowie über das fernsehen und
internet über corona das regelwerk sowie
den notwendigen maßnahmen zum schutz vor
erkrankungen informiert das ist leider
nicht so es gibt keine niedrigschwellige
informationsangebote in der
muttersprache und jemand ohne
sprachkenntnisse nur wenig oder gar
nicht beziehungsweise die mich lesen
können auch nach wie vor wird das in
deutschland sehr unterschätzt
wir haben einen analphabetismus problem
insbesondere die erste generation der
multi mit migrationshintergrund die mit
dem alter die zweite sprache erlernen
spätestens mit der demenz erkrankung da
fühlt sich von den informationskanälen
die menschen nicht angesprochen also ist
es doch wieder eine frage welche
informationen erreicht welche gruppe
dann hat es nicht etwas mit armut zu tun
sondern doch auch was mit herkunft
roddick ist wie würden sie das ganze
sehen wir haben hier bei uns im kreis
mit beginn der zweiten welle versucht zu
verstehen wo sind denn die infektion und
warum sind die infektion werben relativ
schon im frühherbst gemerkt dass gerade
menschen mit migrationshintergrund sehr
häufig betroffen sind und haben genau
das was hdd eben angesprochen hat auch
gemacht wir haben informations videos
gedreht weil wir gesagt haben nur
alleine papier bringt gar nichts wir
haben das in 17 muttersprachen gemacht
mit menschen die selbst aus diesem aus
dieser gruppe kommen aus dem heer
konzentrationen haben das über die
migrations bei rede über das außer der
farben gespielt
aber waren das aber wenn sie jetzt sagen
dass eben veranstalter situation fällt
dieses migrations migrationshintergrund
auf ist es nicht die frauen angesagt
dann doch eher ein verdienst problem
also war es tatsächlich nur menschen mit
einem bestimmten so zur kulturellen
background oder sind das nicht auch
menschen gewesen die zum beispiel hat es
hier beziehen weil von denen wissen wir
die haben ein signifikant höheres risiko
auf einer intensivstation zu landen als
menschen die arbeiten gehen menschen die
zb von hartz 4 leben haben sehr oft
überhaupt gesundheitliche probleme weil
das thema ernährung auch eine rolle
spielt gesunder lebenswandel
da gibt es viele studien nein das würde
ich an der stelle bei uns jetzt nicht so
sehen wir erfassen ja zum beispiel auch
das thema wo arbeiten menschen in
welchem beruflichen kontext haben sie
sich angesteckt oder eventuell auch
infektionen weitergegeben und da haben
wir keinen unterschied ob es jetzt wie
eben gesagt wurde der fließbandarbeiter
war oder ob wir in einer behörde sitzen
wir haben an allen stellen menschen die
sich infizieren
da ist der große unterschied nicht da
der ist tatsächlich bei uns zu sehen in
der frage migrationshintergrund herkunft
und da auch nicht überall so wir haben
positive erfahrungen gemacht ich habe
gesagt wir haben versucht auch wirklich
kontakte zu knüpfen mit verschiedenen
bevölkerungsgruppen und zum beispiel
jetzt mit der die debatte seien
unglaublich konstruktiver austausch der
imam imam hat freitags in der moschee
auch berichtet hat darauf hingewiesen
wir haben gemerkt dass gerade in diesem
bereich auch die infektionszahlen
deutlich zurückgegangen sind also das
hat gewirkt aber in anderen bereichen
merken wir und da gebe ich ja absolut
recht es gibt nationen in denen corona
ganz anders gesehen wird als bei uns in
dem man vielleicht das ganze ein
bisschen banalisiert und das merken wir
das spielt sich dann auch das einspielen
herkunftsland durchaus hier wieder dass
also das haben wir nicht nicht im ansatz
überall aber schon bei einigen gruppen
im bereich osteuropäischer herkunft
insbesondere wenn es um das thema
freikirchen oder familien die sich nicht
integriert haben die also in ihrer
eigenen community leben und dort ihre
eigenen regeln haben dort haben wir sehr
häufig gemerkt dass man mit dem thema
nichts anfangen kann das auch unsere
nachforschungen ins leere laufen dass
wir keine kontaktpersonen bekommen und
wir haben das im bereich von menschen
mit flucht
erfahrung auch dort greift das was wir
versuchen mit dolmetschern mit allem
leider gottes nicht immer auch wenn
menschen infiziert sind merken wir wir
treffen die an im supermarkt oder sonst
irgendwo als es wird sich auch nicht
unbedingt ein quarantäne gehalten und
dadurch wird natürlich das virus auch
weiterverbreitet
jetzt müssen natürlich sagen dass sie
sind landrätin von einem kreis in
deutschland von bad kreuznach das heißt
man müsste mal so ein bisschen aufpassen
dass man das nicht verallgemeinert was
in einem landkreis passiert ist deswegen
hat mein kollege jan friedrich fischer
mal versucht zusammenzufassen was es so
an daten sonst noch gibt es ist nicht
viel aber was es gibt hat er für uns in
einem beitrag gepackt bei der 7 tage in
the dance ist köln spitzenreiter und
zwar bei den deutschen großstädten
der wert liegt hier bei 230 doch schaut
man etwas genauer hin wird klar
innerhalb der domstadt ist die korona
lage sehr unterschiedlich im stadtteil
chorweiler lag die inzidenz zuletzt bei
520 nur wenige kilometer weiter in
braunsfeld ist die inzidenz nur
zweistellig wie kann das sein
der blick auf die stadtteile liefert
erste hinweise in braunsfeld gibt es pro
adresse rund sieben einwohner in
chorweiler sind es knapp dreimal so
viele
zudem gibt es prozentual mehr hochhäuser
und einen deutlich höheren
migrationsanteil zugleich gibt es knapp
doppelt so viele schüler sowie mehr
arbeitslosigkeit bei der bundestagswahl
bekam die afg in chorweiler mehr
zweitstimmen aber haben solche faktoren
wirklich einen einfluss auf das
infektionsgeschehen möglich eine analyse
von infas 360 gibt erste hinweise
es gibt in stetten wiederkehrende
beobachtung aber noch keine kausalität
zudem fehlt es bundesweit an daten und
regionen sind unterschiedlich doch
experten plädieren dafür bestimmte
faktoren mehr in den blick zu nehmen vor
allem sozioökonomische und vor allem
anti corona maßnahmen gezielter
einzusetzen und je nach region
anzupassen
wie wichtig wäre so ein ansatz ein
hinweis gibt das lka
dort hieß es unlängst im dezember und
januar lag die kogit 19 sterblichkeit in
sozial stark benachteiligten regionen um
rund 50 bis 70 prozent höher
in regionen mit geringer sozialer
benachteiligung so hätte die haben wir
tatsächlich genug wissen um überhaupt
eine qualifizierte debatte führen zu
können was meinen sie
ich finde nicht bei leider wird darüber
nicht gesprochen
es gibt noch zwei gruppen die wir nicht
vergessen dürfen
zum einen die die älteren menschen mit
migrationshintergrund der ersten
generation die überwiegend in der die
heute beendeten die überwiegend in der
produzierenden industrie dh in
schichtarbeit mit körperlich
anstrengenden tätigkeiten und oft
schlechten hygienischen bedingungen
gearbeitet haben darüber hinaus viele
überstunden
dies führt heute treu von chronischen
erkrankungen die die deutlich über dem
bundesdurchschnitt liegen und dieser
belastung findet sich natürlich genau
unter nichtmigranten mit einem indischen
arbeitsprogramm vier aus stadt und die
dritte generation die heute jüngeren
menschen die wir leider völlig übersehen
das sind junge menschen jugendliche mit
muslimischem migrationshintergrund haben
nunmehr seit einem jahr keine
möglichkeit mehr sich mit ihren freunden
zu treffen
es gibt für sie nicht die möglichkeit
freunde nach hause einzuladen weil sie
in der regel bis zu ihrem hochzeit weil
den eltern den oft recht beengten
wohnverhältnissen leben und es nicht
üblich dass freunde mit nach hause zu
bringen
die jungen münchen trafen sich vor
coraline cafés diskotheken bars dort
wollten sie ihre freiheiten ausleben
leise alkohol trinken freunde treffen
und auch die nähe zum anderen geschlecht
suchen ohne den mahnenden blick der
eltern im nacken zu spüren und diese
ganzen freiheiten sind so wichtig für
jugendliche mit muslimischem hintergrund
weil sie sie noch gar nicht so lange
haben und dies eher ein phänomen der
dritten generation wären jugendliche mit
deutscher kultur hintergrund dieser
freiheiten schon lange genießen und
diese nunmehr seit einem jahr
unterdrückten bedürfnisse führen
eventuell er zum ungehorsam gegenüber
dem
bestehenden regelwerk also würden sie
doch sagen das hat etwas damit zu tun
wie man aufwächst mit was für einer
erziehung man aufwächst und das hat
etwas damit zu tun wo die eltern
herkommen mit sicherheit spielt das auch
eine rolle aber was man auch sagen muss
es ja auch viele institutionelle
variieren fehlende
zielgruppenspezifische angebote im
gesundheitssystem beratung in der
muttersprache fehlende klare konzepte
für die versorgung von menschen mit
migrationshintergrund aber auch die
bürokratische hürde und eine bringschuld
führen zu überforderungen besonders wenn
die sprachbarrieren da sind und
mangelnde interkulturelle kompetenz bei
den bediensteten im gesundheitssystem
erlebe ich tagtäglich und wie gesagt
fehlen der interkulturelle öffnung der
einrichtungen und das bekommen die er
gerade zu spüren
ich guck mal in die kommentare weil die
sind ja wichtig hier da gibt es
teilweise aufregung also ich sehe hier
kevin asamoah hat sich gerade gemeldet
der meinst du migrationshintergründe
gleich corona das kann nicht deren ernst
sein vermute dahinter dann gibt es eine
meldung von georg thomsen an ihre
adresse frau dickes freikirchen euer
ernst
es gibt weit auch weitaus mehr nationen
für die deko maßnahmen nicht
nachzuvollziehen sind wie kann man in
dieser argumentation das wort streik ich
in den mund nehmen und dann eine
beschwerde auch in ihre richtung frau
amalie dass die die erste frage nicht
beantwortet haben beide zum in
bereitschaft
ob die kulturell quasi ausgeprägter ist
woanders können wir nachher noch
besprechen wir gerne sprechen
also habe ich in der frage gar nicht
vernommen sondern nicht sollte er auf
den meeren entspannter unternehmen
zusammen die frage gibt es quasi
kulturen die impf bereit das sind als
andere
das können wir euch nochmal besprechen
ich finde gerade diese sache mit den
freikirchen weil das ist ein großes
problem was auch an der vorbereitung von
diesem von diesem gespräch hatten
worüber reden wir eigentlich gerade ja
migrantinnen ist ein so großer begriff
der so viele menschen gruppen in
deutschland zusammen fast dass es fast
gar nicht möglich ist darüber einen
übereinander zu sprechen deswegen
vielleicht nochmal frau dickes können
si die erfahrungen die sie gemacht haben
denn bad kreuznach konkretisieren sie
haben von freikirchen gesprochen von
deutschrussen da vielleicht noch mal die
frage sind das menschen die auch
geringverdiener sind oder sind das
menschen wo sie sagen die haben ja gut
bezahlte oder oder mittelständische
berufe das heißt dass mit dem mit dem
einkommen nichts zu tun
also haben das eben erst mal schon mal
sehr richtig ausgedrückt dass man nicht
zu weinen kamm scheren kann und dass ich
das auch mitnichten möchte und mir sehr
wohl bewusst ist dass die mehrzahl der
menschen hier vielleicht mit ihren
kulturellen eigenarten aber sehr
integriert oder auch staatstreue
gesetzestreu hier in unserem land agiert
und trotzdem gibt es auch immer mal
wieder gruppen die das einfach auch
nicht wollen und wir haben schon seit
september diese erfahrung in mehreren
gruppierungen gemacht dass wir größere
ausbrüche hatten
das ist sehr schwierig war informationen
zu bekommen und das a und o ist ja dass
wir auch die kontaktpersonen in
quarantäne stellen damit infektionen
nicht weitergetragen werden können und
dass es gerade auch es ist nicht der
einzige punkt aber eben auch in diesem
gruppierung sehr sehr schwierig ist da
reinzukommen und gerade letzte woche mit
unserem ausbruch ist es uns richtig
schwierig gefallen wird aber immer
freude auskünfte zunächst bekommt man
hat absolut gemauert genau und das ist
nicht die erste station die die wie frau
armani sagt ihr das problem haben dass
sie eben nicht genug verdienen und
deswegen auch in solchen verhältnissen
leben oder sind es menschen die aus dem
anderen background kommen ein
das sind menschen die in den
unterschiedlichsten berufen arbeiten und
wir leben auf dem land das heißt bei uns
ohnehin eher nicht der punkt dass man es
zu beengt wohnt also das erleben wir
dort nicht aber noch aber ich möchte
nicht eine gruppe stigmatisieren im
gegenteil was unser ansatz war und das
seit oktober besser gesagt hat wir
wollen verstehen was passiert ist und
was können wir dagegen tun und wir haben
mit aufklärung wirklich versuchten
niederschwellig in den muttersprachen zu
agieren wir haben uns immer wieder auch
menschen geholt die in ihrer community
rein wirken die das auf die sozialen
netzwerke
haben damit das lesen nicht das problem
sein soll und wir scheitern an dieser
stelle bis zu einem gewissen punkt
werden manche erreicht und das klappt
auch gut und auch die meisten deutschen
würde ich behaupten kennen nicht
sämtliche chor ohne regeln
das kann ich absolut nachvollziehen und
das auch nicht jeder alles versteht das
verstehe ich auch aber den sachsen stand
darauf sollte man mittlerweile können ja
ich habe hier eine wortmeldung von sofia
elli schreibt die politik ist in der
verantwortung entsprechende deutsch
kurse anzubieten wenn die politik
versagt sondern kann man nicht die
menschen mit ausländischen wurzeln dafür
verantwortlich machen also da ist es
wieder eine schwierige gemengelage wer
hat jetzt eigentlich welche
verantwortung
aber frau armani ist es wirklich
komplett von der hand zu weisen das ist
natürlich hinaus ist es nicht bitte die
sprache ist es nicht sprache ist ja
nicht das problem mit dem wir hier
arbeiten
das ist manchmal schwierig aber das ist
nicht das grundproblem ich habe selbst
schon tageweise in der stabsstelle
menschen angerufen da mag das manchmal
in der grammatik nicht richtig sein aber
das ist nicht das problem ich glaube
dass ganz grobe versteht jeder und nur
das ist auch wirklich wichtig man muss
nicht jedes detail an der regel kennen
abstand maske kontakt reduktion ich
glaube das hat jeder zumindest gehört
und ver di hat ja gerade schon in allen
gruppen hdd hat er gerade schon gesagt
es gibt teilweise sprachbarrieren machen
wir die frage an frau armani
auch wenn sie betonen dass es natürlich
ein ein sozi ökonomische problem ist
dass menschen zu wenig verdienen und
deswegen einen schwierigen
arbeitsverhältnissen sind in schwierigen
verhältnissen sind ist das komplett von
der hand zu weisen dass eine gewisse
erziehung auch einer aus einer kultur
kommen dazu beitragen kann dass man zum
beispiel sagt ich verlass mich nicht auf
institutionen das ist etwas was auch
studien aus österreich zum beispiel
ergeben haben menschen mit afghanischen
syrischen background sind extrem
vorsichtig gewesen extrem misstrauisch
wenn sie etwas von einer institution
gehört haben und sagen das glaube ich
erst mal nicht also kann man das
wirklich von der hand weisen dass es
dann auch solche eigenheiten gibt ich
finde es einfach schade und auch sehr
bezeichnend dass frau dick ist oder
jetzt eben stellvertretend für die cdu
daraus eine herkunft debatte macht wobei
sich das ganze land auch leute die sich
widersprechen auch leute die vielleicht
mir in sachen widersprechen
im moment sehr sehr einig sind dass
dass das ganze land ist sich einig dass
sozial schwache betroffen sind übrigens
nicht nur in deutschland das ist ja ein
weltweites problem überall wo es eine
große schere gibt zwischen arm und reich
sind die ärmeren von krisen betroffen so
das ist in brasilien so das ist in den
usa ganz stark so und das so komplett
von der hand zu weisen dass sie sagt
alle berufe sind betroffen wenn sie sich
überlegen wie viele menschen ich habe
vorhin auch gesagt ich bin aus einer
privilegierten position jetzt das war
ich früher nicht aber ich bin jetzt
leute sitzen im home office mit ihrem
cappuccino in ihren schicken
altbauwohnungen so die die bürgerliche
ich finde das sehr interessant dass ihr
vorhin so den sündenbock auch so nacht
nach osteuropa geworfen hat und gesagt
hat da haben wir auch die erfahrungen
dass die leute irgendwie genau aber dass
sie zum beispiel da hatten wir letztes
jahr ein riesenskandal wo ganz
deutschland darüber gesprochen hat wo wo
zigtausende rumänen nach deutschland
gebracht wurden um hier spargel zu
stechen und in massenunterkünften
untergebrachten haben so damit wir damit
sich die leute die sich den spargel
leisten können so die die wieder die die
bürgerliche mitte oder eben oberschicht
so ihren spargel essen können so ich bin
einfach es ist also ist es klar also
dass die cdu diese position hält und es
ist sicherlich kurz vom wahlkampf auch
sehr praktisch dann noch mal irgendwie
auch leute zu mobilisieren die sagen ja
dass das problem sind die den andere
kultur haben und so es ist ganz klar
sind da arme menschen betroffen es gibt
eine studie von von kinderärzte die hat
glaube ich die pronova durchgeführt und
da war eine studie über hat das
ärzteblatt berichtet 150 niedergelassene
ärzte wurden gefragt wie viele patienten
sie haben die in der korona zeit da ging
es gar nicht um corona sondern dass
kinder aus sozial schwachen haushalten
komplett mit und ohne
migrationshintergrund wie die darunter
leiden dass sie in kleinen wohnungen
sind wie sie darunter leiden dass sie
teilweise wohnungsnot so bestimmt gar
nicht in eine moderne günstige wohnung
finden können dumpinglöhne kann er kenne
keine gerechteren verteilung das gibt
und es ist sehr sehr schade ich finde
ich persönlich finde es immer sehr stark
dass du selbst wenn du eine position an
gehör ist also mir wäre es jetzt auch
sehr bequem zu sagen ach quatsch ich bin
doch als als eliza armani genauso
betroffen wie die
krankenschwester und der busfahrer und
der am fließband arbeite ist es einfach
nicht wahr
und dazu gibt es gerade studien und
selbst von leuten die sich eigentlich
eher sonst uneinig sind sind sich alle
gerade einig dass armut in deutschland
ein thema ist auch in allen anderen
ländern ist es jetzt nicht so dass nur
wir in deutschland das irgendwie falsch
machen oder so das passieren weltweit
ist das eine krise und dass menschen
eben also die menschen die wie gesagt
dieses land am laufen halten sind
betroffene aus zeitgründen so die die
kein auto haben die die mit mehreren
kindern im haushalt alleine die können
sich gründer zu uns bekommen nicht nein
nicht vor allem sondern haben sondern
auch natürlich auch also das ist gut das
weiß ich auch nicht von der hand ist es
ganz klar auch der fall und man will
dass die formen muss man ja auch genau
nach der wurzel schauen so wer wird wie
ausgeartet das werden jetzt von der
debatte so groß wie oft habe ich jetzt
leute mit denen ich mich unterhalte wo
dir dann sagen was du nicht was weiß ich
ich baue auf der grundschule ich habe
direkt eine hauptschul zuweisungen
bekommen und kann er hat gesehen dass
sich da ein riesentalent hatte in dem
unter dem fach um mir eine gymnasial
zuweisung zu geben als beispiel jetzt
ich bin jemand ich bin direkt aufs
gymnasium gekommen so ich hatte das
glück aber man muss auch so aus der
perspektive einer einer privilegierten
person oder einer person die mehr geld
zur verfügung hat ganz klar sehen dass
ärmere menschen von krisen grundsätzlich
welche krise betroffen sind und daraus
jetzt geschickt in der wahl situation so
eine situation zu machen zu sagen ja die
wollen sich kulturell ja nicht so
richtig und die eltern sind dagegen und
stand auch dann tatsächlich dann so
ländern
solche erfahrungen hat erfahrungen wie
ich versuchte zu erreichen und die
halten sich nicht daran
die machen nicht mit die man gehen
achten die quarantäne verordnungen und
julian ist es sagt ihre beobachtung ja
gesagt hat war es vor allem diese eine
freikirche mit deutschrussen die hat
auffällig war ja wir haben es ja in den
kommentaren gesehen das ist sehr schade
ist weil eben genau das was sie gerade
geleugnet hat zu tun nämlich eine
stigmatisierung genau das findet ja
statt wenn ich wenn ich so namen nenne
sie haben vorhin gesagt afghanen und
syrien
wenn ich anfange durch welche gerade
erst findet der abzug aus afghanistan
statt also versteht ich will jetzt gar
nicht so aus wenn wir jetzt über die
pandemie sprechen zusammen am main war
ja dort wenden wollen wir nur gerade zu
ende
noch sprechen darf sie waren auch als
ich dann waren sie gesprochen aber wenn
ich dann noch zu ende führen darf zb
jetzt gerade also wenn man muss sich
natürlich für jedes land spezifisch dann
anschauen wo wo es was passiert welches
land war von wie vielen kriegen belastet
weil was ist da ich kenne viele frauen
wissen welches vertrauen gibt es in
institution also das ist immer größer
als wenn es ist sehr so demagogisch und
sehr so populistisch oder polemisch
jetzt einfach zu kommen und zu sagen ja
die afghanen die glauben nimmt die syrer
also es sind sie benennen da völker wo
hochqualifizierte menschen in diesem
land sind und die fand natürlich dass
menschen mit sprachbarrieren ganz klar
natürlich gibt es menschen die noch
nicht so erreicht oder es gibt
kriminelle in jeder gruppe so aber es
liegt halt jetzt daran wo setze ich den
fokus so sage ich jetzt das ist ein
bisschen ein problem die die immer in
den alle wollen wir jetzt wirklich die
pandemie zu naiv aber krise machen und
sagen weil die nicht in die in den start
so dass es ein bisschen so nicht so weit
im vorfeld ja ich fand sogar die
kommentare sehr sehr angenehm über schön
und fand die leute haben mir gesagt
facetime und sich am kopf gefasst dass
dann plötzlich ihr freikirche feld so
dass ihr platz als sicherlich gibt es
immer und ich muss es auch geben aber
ich werde ja auch wie gesagt ich habe
keine wahl kampagne und kein buch zum
thema kein das aber ich möchte einfach
wenn sie ganz klar meine frau meine
antwort die ich mir natürlich auch aus
verschiedenen studien und sachen und mir
angucke was sagen die ärzte
was sagen die leute die in diesem die
pflege es ist ein armutsproblem wo
natürlich auch leute teil mit
migrationshintergrund auch betroffen
sind und aus man auch gucken warum aber
genauso viele menschen gibt es die zum
beispiel behinderungen haben und
deswegen in die armut gerutscht sind es
gibt menschen die aus um zig gründen in
der armut sind und dass dann das dass
falls das ev dicke sagt er so wenn die
cdu jetzt wirklich der meinung ist dass
das in allen berufsschichten natürlich
das risiko sich anzustecken besteht
überall so sie und nicht wenn gerade pro
tag dreimal getestet irgendwie risiko
ist gleich hoch aber wie habe ich mich
finanziell schwacher dargestellt bin die
möglichkeit uns zu schützen wenn ich auf
meinen beruf
wenn ich eine pause nehmen das wort ja
also ich schreibe gerade kein buch und
ich bin auch nicht im wahlkampf wohl ich
bin auch nicht für die cdu heute hier
sondern als verantwortliche für meinen
landkreis und so sehe ich mich und so
gucke ich mir zahlen genau an und
versuche zu verstehen und versuche zu
helfen
und trotz allem merken wir und das sehe
ich jetzt gerade hier in meiner
kreisstadt mit 50.000 einwohnern dass
wir hier in dieser stadt zwei drittel
der infizierten mit
migrationshintergrund haben und ich will
da nicht weggucken sondern wir müssen
aus meiner sicht genau hinschauen um zu
wissen wo sind infektionen greifen die
maßnahmen die wir treffen erreichen wir
damit mehr schutz für die bevölkerung
das ist an manchen stellen und da finde
ich sollte ja auch nicht jede maßnahme
der bundesregierung jetzt wenn sie
allgemein gefasst wird auf einen
einzelnen kreis vielleicht passend das
ist für mich der hintergrund und wir
nochmal das ist jetzt nicht eine
stigmatisierung dass eine feststellung
übrigens habe ich von menschen mit
flucht erfahrung gesprochen und keine
einzige bevölkerungs oder keine nation
benannt weil ich das noch nicht richtig
finde das sind menschen die andere
erfahrung haben und genauso wie sie
gesagt haben
genauso wie sie gesagt haben natürlich
auch mit der erfahrung ihres
heimatlandes vielleicht hierher kommen
und das ist eine prägen die man
mitbringt und deswegen ist der mensch
nicht schlechter und nicht besser
der ist so wie er ist aber es ist doch
unsere aufgabe und das ist meine schauen
kommt es dass manche maßnahmen ergreifen
wird der auch die bevölkerung sprechen
können ja klar das ist mir bewusst aber
ist die angst vor dem was andere machen
der grund dass man wahrheiten auch nicht
ausspricht das ist jetzt für mich schon
ein ganz wichtiger punkt nicht
stigmatisieren und gegenteil ich möchte
aber genau wissen haut und wenn man
etwas bemerkt dann auch klar regen der
hat lange nichts gesagt aber er hat
gerade was wichtig ist ja sagt deswegen
gebe ich ihm gleich das wort nachdem wir
uns den beitragen geguckt haben weil sie
haben gesagt hätte die es gibt ein
sprach- und ein informationsproblem so
und da haben wir uns doch mal genauer
angeguckt was das eigentlich bedeutet
und wie wir da gerade aufgestellt sind
in dieser krise ich glaube das war im
winter zweiter
20 das ganze land auf uns schauen wenn
der unsichtbare gefahr bedrohte alles
woran wir klopfen
also fassen wir alle unser mut zusammen
und taten was von uns erwartet wurde
das einzig richtige
wir türken nichts eine corona kampagne
der bundesregierung sie kehrt auch auf
deutsch
das verstehen viele aber nicht alle die
hier leben aber es gibt sie
informationen zum corona virus in
anderen sprachen dann allerdings
schriftlich und nüchtern zum beispiel
auf arabisch oder auch auf bulgarisch
polnisch kurdisch französisch türkisch
oder russisch wird informiert vom
bundesgesundheitsamt und übersetzt vom
ethno medizinischen zentrum einem
gemeinnützigen verein
ihr vorteil jahrelange erfahrung und
kontakt zu den communitys ramazan salman
engagiert sich seit 1992 für das ethno
medizinische zentrum sein ziel alle
menschen medizinisch informieren in
möglichst vielen sprachen höchste zeit
für mich kam das schleppend 23 monate zu
spät meiner meinung nach das ist nichts
neues für mich es ist leider immer noch
nicht in deutschland
normalität geworden zu bedenken dass ja
diverse bevölkerung haben über die
zusammenarbeit mit gesundheitsämtern
erreichen sie über eine millionen
menschen
mehrsprachig informiert wird aber auch
analog sowie vom interkulturellen
aufklärungs team in berlin neukölln sind
hier keine steam von sprachmittler
die leute kurz beraten zu allgemeinen
fragen um krone herum um die
verhaltensregeln und jetzt mittlerweile
aber auch ein bisschen zum thema impfung
nur wer informiert ist kann sich ohne
hürden für einen impftermin anmelden
egal ob mit oder ohne deutschkenntnisse
so ich guck mal in die kommentare weil
die haben wir auch noch nie so viel
beachtet ist immer schwierig wenn der
gesprächspartner haben die galaxie
schreibt hier ich finde frau dickes
aussage nicht grenzwertig ich befinde
mich momentan quarantäne und halte mich
an alle regeln und ich gehe erst mal von
dem namen aus dass du auch in migrations
background hass darunter john franklin
meint das ist eine fake news der cdu im
osten wo die fdp stark ist ist auch
kuwait weit verbreitet das hatten wir
schon lange geklärt
außerdem wortmeldung jetzt zu dem thema
was wir gerade hatten informationen also
einmal gibt es von marcel die bemerkung
aufklärung dieser menschen ist wichtig
ich habe schon häufig ein verhalten
beobachtet dass ich in dieser situation
nicht nachvollziehen kann
das liegt meistens an mangelnder
aufklärung oder ignoranz und angel fügt
hinzu vor allem wäre es wichtig auch die
eltern infos des landes den kitas in
verschiedenen sprachen zur verfügung zu
stellen so kann man niederschwellig den
eltern infos in ihrer sprache zur
verfügung stellen und die kitas
entlasten denn unserer kita ist es sehr
wichtig alle familien gut und gleich zu
informieren herr delhi wenn sie das noch
mal konkretisieren können die
erfahrungen die wir gerade gehört haben
teilweise sind die informationen nur im
internet verfügbar oder halt nicht in
allen sprachen sind das erfahrungen die
sie auch machen und was müssen sich da
ändern
genau die erfahrungen mache ich
tatsächlich tagtäglich und viele vereine
viele gemeinden fühlen sich da auch
allein gelassen
das problem ist ich finde wir müssen in
deutschland darüber sprechen und auch
debattieren ehrlich und offen um den
ursachen an die wurzeln gehen zu können
ist auch dieser aspekt finde ich sehr
wichtig natürlich besteht immer die
gefahr dass von rechten gruppen
gruppierungen und dann gleich die these
lauten wird
dass migranten sich nicht an die regeln
halten und deshalb häufiger an carola
erkranken
ich finde wir brauchen diese daten aber
dringend um genauer hinsehen zu kennen
denn nur so können wir auch ursachen
herausfinden und lösungsansätze
erarbeiten
und wenn wir darüber sprechen dann
müssen wir auch die rosa anwenden und
ich finde das wird nicht so viel gemacht
leider
wir wissen bereits dass hier in köln und
auch in anderen großstädten stadtteilen
in denen besonders viele menschen von
transferleistungen abhängig sind
deutlich stärker von corona betroffen
sind da zum beispiel durch die
stadtteile wie sie ja auch im video
gezeigt haben und dieser umstand liegt
er nahe dass weniger diäten als vielmehr
die sozioökonomische status der männchen
eine rolle bei twitter erkrankungen
spielt das heißt insolvent ist ganz klar
zu sagen darf jemand der ein background
hat wie sie frau armani
deutsch-iranische aber gut verdienend
ökonomisch gut gestellt der hat auch die
entsprechende bildung und hat deswegen
auch die möglichkeiten sich zu
informieren liest vielleicht
verschiedene medien und menschen die das
nicht haben sei es jetzt weil sie einen
migrationshintergrund haben und deswegen
auch stigmatisiert werden aufgrund der
bildung oder menschen die hat sowieso
nicht so viele bilder mitbekommen haben
aus welchem grund auch immer müssen in
ein arbeitsverhältnis hinten arbeiten wo
sie weniger sich aus sich aussetzen und
die haben die gleichen
informationsproblem ich finde dass er
mich es ginge hier also ich finde es
wird einfach quasi wie so ein sündenbock
kreiert und auch wenn man dann 500 mal
sagt so ich möchte nicht stigmatisieren
oder es geht uns ja allen darum ist
irgendwie schnell aus dieser situation
wieder rauskommen und so weiter wird
mache ich aber dann genau das also man
muss ja auch gucken so man spricht er
auch als politiker für die breite masse
und wenn man dann eben so man hat eben
das so konstruiert dass man sagt aber es
ist ein kulturelles und brück dass wir
die richtig gesagt hat es drückt ja bei
vielen rechten muss jetzt nicht dass das
es auch eine randgruppe aber das drückt
bei vielen rechten genau die richtigen
knöpfe sowas dann unten ankommt bei
denen es
oh ja es ist ein kulturelles problem mit
wollen sie das nicht mehr machen dann
ist vielleicht warum seine frau dick ist
auch sehr interessant ihre perspektive
zu hören kann es vielleicht einfach sein
dass diese menschen natürlich er
auffallend weil sie jetzt nicht so diese
diesen bundesdeutschen durchschnitt
entsprechend ich mache bewusst
gänsefüßchen männer sind menschen die
einfache migrationshintergrund haben
jetzt hat er drauf guckt und dann eher
auffällt ach guck mal der schmeißt den
flyer in den in den müll den ich gerade
gegeben hat während das bei einer frau
schmidt die blond ist und aussieht wie
eine normale deutsche hausfrau das nicht
so auffällt roddick ist ich sehe ja gar
nicht ob jemand den flyer nimmt oder
nicht und ich glaube das wäre wirklich
stigmatisierend weil es viele menschen
gibt egal welcher herkunft die sich an
viele dinge halten und ich weiß noch mal
daraufhin ich gucke ja nur in die zahlen
darauf die auf die zahlen die wir hier
im landkreis haben und ich sehe dort
gerade dort in den städten dass wir
diese zwei drittel schon durchgehend
seit herbst immer wieder auch haben zwei
drittel der menschen der infizierten
haben migrationshintergrund und da geht
es nicht um das thematisieren warum
haben die nicht aber warum auf dem magen
und erreichten projekten wollte
ökonomischen und dabei sind irgendwann
zwischen leute trauen dann wäre ich ja
auch gemeint und da werden ja auch
andere menschen gemeint die adapter da
ist dann wieder dieses leute mit
migrationshintergrund weit und nur die
die ordentlich integriert sind leute die
nicht ordentlich integriert sind was
auch immer das heißt das wort wird sehr
sehr freien verwendet so geht es darum
sprache geht es um kultur geht es darum
dass man goethe und schiller liszt oder
versteht oder geht es nur darum dass es
jemand auf einer anderen sprache ist
dass die debatte ist und wo es anfällt
dann sind wir ja dann sind wir da bin
ich da ist mein vater war ich obwohl ich
vielleicht ein besseres deutsch spreche
als er also bei mir geht es einfach nur
darum ich ganz klar auch wenn ich mir
gesamt anschaue so was da so gestartet
wird wie sagt man gesagt wird in letzter
zeit auch von seiten der cdu die ja
eigentlich keine rechte partei ist in
dem sinne sich mitte rechts irgendwo
ansiedelt das finde ich sehr schade ist
es ist es ganz klassisch fantasiert von
für mich einen sehr wichtigen satz oder
1 bezeichneten satz gesagt sie haben sie
haben sie haben herr peter auf ganz
deutlich gefragt
hat das auch was mit dem sozialen
hintergrund zu tun und frau dick ist hat
das verneint sie sagt da ist findet an
allen so uns ist einfach unfair zu sagen
dass es a
die vielleicht in der villa sitzt und
mit ihrem mercedes durch die gegend
fahren kann die gleichen probleme hat
wie der busfahrer der wenig geld zur
verfügung hat sich nicht in der form
distanzieren kann weil einer kleinen
wohnung lebt weil er am fließband die es
wird einfach gerade nicht klar gesagt
dass die großindustrie gerade deren
interessen extrem gewahrt werden so
fließband ist erlaubt aber der alte
rentner ohne migrationshintergrund der
deutsche alte rentner vielleicht alleine
ist kann abends nicht spazieren gehen
weil das ist das ist nicht erlaubt aber
am fließband dürfen wir stehen es ist
das plötzlich ganz ist es mittlerweile
wissen auf reise ist es nicht nein aber
es steht also wenn sie sich verschiedene
also wenn meinung man hat sich im moment
meinungen von rechts und links und alle
sind der meinung dass das im moment
schon lächerlich ist dass die das dient
das die interessen der großindustrie
gewahrt werden während dann an an kann
kleinerer schraube gedreht wird die die
finanziell schwachen betrieb unter
appartement und dann wenn sie weltweit
schauen wenn es natürlich probleme
infrage lohnend und das gleiche problem
ist in amerika die sozial schwachen die
teilweise gar keinen
migrationshintergrund kein
amerikanischen migrationshintergrund
haben oder dass 20 generation her ist
sind auch die sozial schwachen betroffen
das ist schwierig ich wissen diese
hitzige diskussion zu führen die ich ja
gut finde diskutieren dass frau dickes
hat einfach eine latenz nennen wir das
im fernsehen
es dauert ein bisschen bis sie uns hören
kann und dann reinrutschen können das
wäre einfacher wenn wir im studio
zusammen setzen aber das geht vielen
gründen nicht so frau dickes also die
frage die ich gerade hatte wenn sie
sagen dass sie es fällt ihnen auf zwei
dritteln ihrer infizierten haben einen
sogenannten migrationshintergrund haben
sie dann auch geguckt ob das nicht
vielleicht auch einfach also kraft kann
sie auch einfach nach einkommen und
können sagen zwei drittel haben einmal
mit der veränderung
also ich kann mich ja zum beispiel auch
das thema was eben angesprochen wurde
sind das die fließbandarbeiter beziehen
und da habe ich ja zu beginn gesagt nein
wir sehen von den beruflichen herkunft
natürlich im bereich der pflege als er
die vielen fällen den alten
hatten hatten wir auch sehr viele
pflegefälle die pflegekräfte die
infiziert waren keine frage das hat aber
nichts mit beengten wohnverhältnissen
sondern einfach mit der situation in
unseren altenheim in unseren kliniken zu
tun
das erleben wir heute nicht mehr weil
dort das thema impfung nach vorne geht
und ansonsten sage ich was die
berufsauffassung betrifft da sind wir
breit gestreut und da kann ich nicht
sagen weil jemand mehr oder weniger
verdient ich mein abo dann kenne ich ja
auch person ist er mehr betroffen
ich sehe und das ist einzig und allein
meine aussage gewesen dass zwei drittel
der menschen gerade in unseren städten
und das sind meine zwei städte hier die
kreisstadt und auch die kleinere stadt
kirn zwei drittel der infizierten
migrationshintergrund haben und das ist
nicht ein stick man gesehen oder ein
böse sprechen von menschen sondern
einfach eine feststellung und ich finde
wenn wir maßnahmen ergreifen wollen in
der heutigen zeit die passgenau sind
dann müssen wir das wissen dann müssen
wir darüber sprechen und gucken was wir
tun können und deswegen ist zum beispiel
bei uns in 17 sprachen informationen
vorhanden
digital so dass man sie als video gucken
kann und nicht lesen muss und ich würde
gerne viel mehr machen wenn ich wüsste
man erreicht menschen aber da sind wir
da sind wir im moment zumindest die
punkte sagt bekommen nicht ran obwohl
wir es versuchen obwohl ich völlig dabei
beim herrn delhi bin dass man sagt man
muss alles versuchen bei manchen
menschen greift es um bei manchen greift
es nicht manche weil sie uns nicht
verstehen
und manche weil sie ganz bewusst
vielleicht auch aufgrund ihrer herkunft
nationen das thema corona nicht so ernst
nehmen oder auch die regeln nicht
akzeptieren und es ist für mich einfach
eine sehr auffällige zahl und da möchte
ich nicht sagen ich schimpfe oder die
haben einen so zur kulturellen
hintergrund wenn wir von zwei dritteln
sprechen es gibt auch menschen ohne
migrationshintergrund die in beengten
oder armen verhältnissen leben die sind
nicht im ansatz so weit betroffen und
ich kann einen punkt da bin ich richtig
wenn ich in einem großen haus wohne und
eine person ist infiziert dann kann die
sich ab sondern von anderen wenn ich in
einer kleinen wohnung wohnen und wohnen
damit fünf personen dann sind fünf
personen nach infizierter brauchen wir
nicht diskutieren
hast du da spielt das sozioökonomische
ganz sicher eine rolle und das ist auch
ein großer teil der gesellschaft damit
die brutal der
gesellschaft lieber dick es ist ja nicht
in der villa oder in einer
einzimmerwohnung ich habe vier kinder
sie haben ja aber bitte ich habe auch
hier kinder und auch andere haben kinder
und es ist mir völlig klar wenn in einer
familie ein mensch infiziert sind in
allem wenn es sich um kleine familie ist
es sind weniger und wenn es die große
sind ist es mehr das ist mir bewusst und
trotzdem lässt sich eine zeit von zwei
drittel einfach nicht weg diskutieren
und da geht es nicht um ein bisschen
mehr oder ein bisschen weniger sondern
einfach um eine faktum dass wir hier
sehen und auch etwas was uns die ärzte
hier vor ort bestätigen da was die
kliniken mittlerweile auch sagen dass
sie diese menschen da und das ist doch
nicht ein böse reden sondern ein nicht
verschweigen wollen von tatsachen
vielleicht kann ich da versuchen einen
kompromiss zu finden weil man kann das
auch anders rum sehen dass das heute
gesagt okay beobachten dass zwei drittel
haben diesen migrationshintergrund wobei
das ich finde persönlich auch ein
schwieriger begriff ist weil ich würde
auch darunter fallen auch wenn man das
nicht merken würde und das ist
tatsächlich dann vielleicht mit
problembeschreibung wo man sagen kann
okay wir müssen mehr tun diese menschen
zu erreichen damit sie eben nicht zu
opfern werden also ich glaube es ist
einfach so eine täter erholen da aber
sie hat sich in zwei punkten sehr
deutlich auch die ganze zeit am
laufenden band widersprochen uns war die
eine ist dass sie einerseits zugibt dass
ein meilenstein in einer kleinen wohnung
ist was eine große menge in deutschland
ist ich hab vorhin gesagt das ist eine
zahl 16 prozent der menschen in
deutschland sind an der armutsgrenze und
viele viele menschen sind vielleicht
knapp darüber
und das einfach nicht zugibt dass zu und
sagt dann okay das möchte ich gar nicht
das gebe ich zu gleichzeitig nein es ist
kein sozioökonomische problem
das ist natürlich wir haben es mit einer
brandrede zu tun für einen christa klaß
in ihren kreisen sein dass vielleicht
ist er kreis so dass man gut sein und
sie haben ja auch eine wichtige frage
gestellt und haben gesagt haben es
schauen sie dann bei den leuten mit
migrationshintergrund ob das eben leute
sind aus sozial schwächeren wieder
finanziell main kommen aus armut renten
oder wollen sie einfach dann pauschal
das wort menschen mit menschen mit
migrationshintergrund verwenden und es
hat sie ja auch schon beantwortet indem
sie nein es geht zwei drittel das sind
menschen mit migrationshintergrund und
da geht es völlig egal das hat sich auch
genau so gesagt welchen beruf sie aus
erreichen und sie hat gesagt es halt
schwierig erst richtig merken sie
investition zurückholen weil es gerade
still ist in köln
wir kennen diese probleme was kann man
den konkret tun beziehungsweise tut die
politik jetzt auch in köln wo sie sich
besonders gut auskennen in ihren augen
genug um menschen die eben dann auch
opfer der pandemie werden ich glaube das
ist auch wichtig dass man das mal so rum
betrachtet weil diese menschen werden
opfer von diesen von diesem system was
wir teilweise dann auch haben was sie
eben nicht im home office arbeiten
können dass das die besser erreicht
werden und im endeffekt dann nicht mehr
zu opfern werden
also ich denke dass das thema von der
politik tabuisiert wird insbesondere die
ursachen
da sonst versäumnisse eingestanden
werden müssen und wir haben es in
deutschland
das muss ich leider sagen mit einem
ernsthaften diskriminierungs problem zu
tun
wir wissen aus studien dass viele
menschen aufgrund ihres ethnischen
hintergrundes gesellschaftliche
benachteiligung erfahren zb schule
ausbildung kinder mit
migrationshintergrund werden bei
gleicher leistung halbe note schlechter
bewertet oder auch bei bewerbungen und
wohnungssuche und jugendliche mit
ausländischen wurzeln müssen deutlich
mehr bewerbungen schreiben um zu einem
vorstellungsgespräch eingeladen zu
werden
aber tun ich bin sehr viele jahre jetzt
im gesundheitswesen tätig ich besuche
sehr viele veranstaltungen zum thema
interkulturelle öffnung sei es in der
verwaltung sei es im gesundheitswesen
das sind meistens veranstaltungen dass
es so schön und nett aber so wirklich
was ändern soll sich da leider nicht
alleine wenn wir heute im gesundheitsamt
an unterwegs sind
ich sehe da keinerlei piktogramme für
analphabeten allein da fängt schon an
dass wir gar nicht aus dieser gruppe
eingehen und und ich finde alleine in
köln wir haben eine migrationsanteil von
ca 40 prozent und bei kinder und
jugendlichen ist das fast 60 prozent und
wenn ich mir die verwaltung und
besondere leitende tätigkeiten angucken
dann spiegelt sich das überhaupt gar
nicht wieder und ich finde
da müssen wir ansetzen und wir müssen
aufhören zu sprechen sondern einfach zu
machen aber ich finde aber muss die
politik ansetzen
trotzdem noch mal die frage die freude
allerdings hat ja beschrieben sie
versucht die menschen zu erreichen
teilweise scheitert sie kennen sie das
dass es auch tatsächlich dann einfach
nicht funktioniert ich kenne das so
nicht also ich bin im gespräch mit
vielen verbänden mit noch eine moschee
gemeinden auch die immer wieder
rückmelden dass bei denen sich niemand
meldet und zwar nur einen stapel
informationsmaterial bahn lassen aber
ernsthafte kooperation und
zusammenarbeit findet samen nicht und
ich finde es muss vielmehr
informationsveranstaltungen und man muss
die medien auch nutzen die diese
community auch nutzt und das sehe ich
leider nicht ich möchte dir und
beschließen mit einer bord aber jetzt an
dem punkt vielleicht da aber gerade ich
würde behaupten wir sind vorbildlich an
diesem punkt wir haben eine stabstelle
die das hervorragend mit den migrations
beiräten mit einem tollen ausländer
farben dass wir haben tut und trotzdem
erreichen wir nicht und so weit bin ich
dankbar für alles was uns hilft aber wir
haben es mit allen mitteln aus meiner
sicht versucht auch mit menschen die aus
den communitys kommen und scheitern
das lasse ich jetzt mal so stehen ich
möchte die runde beschließen mit einem
anna wortmeldung von andrea landon auf
facebook die sagt ich denke die ganze
corona diskussion ist hoch emotional
dafür steht auch diese runde
ich denke es fehlen einfach belastbare
daten eine klare zielsetzung was und wie
mit diesen daten umzugehen ist und eine
entwicklung zu mehr sachlichkeit und
ehrlichkeit andrea ich danke dir für
diese wortmeldung die ich auch so
unterschreiben würde aber natürlich es
ist hoch emotional weil glaube ich auch
ganz viele themen die übergeordnet sind
mit reinspielen ungerechtigkeit
wirtschaftlicher not armut natürlich das
sind sachen die menschen natürlich auch
zu recht aufregen wir werden weiter in
der debatte bleiben
für heute abend bedanke ich mich für
diese muntere diskussion bei elisa
armani und bei frau dr
trettin im bad kreuznach und bei herrn
delhi in köln vielen dank dass sie dabei
waren und auch vielen dank für eure
kommentare die heute bisschen weniger
mitgespielt haben aber ich habe sie im
blick behalten wie immer und ich sage
bis zum nächsten live stream ich freue
mich drauf macht's gut
und tschüss